the idea of building a new city is
absolutely insane in some people's eyes
why do we need to build new cities and
cities are places where humans live and
Thrive optimally you got to build new
cities so that more humans live more
prosperous lives raw town as a whole
it's a beautiful destination you know
blue transparent Waters white sand it's
a great place to grow a young family if
you want to be part of building the
future that we want to see if you want
to be in the most advanced digital
manufacturing technology then you're in
Prosper if you are at The Cutting Edge
of financial Innovation and you want to
run on on bitcoin for everything but
also if you want to have a low-cost way
to operate because taxes are very low
then you're improsperous all right guys
bang bang I've got Eric here with me uh
I thought a great place to start would
be the idea of building a new city is
absolutely insane in some people's eyes
why do we need to build new cities like
what is the problem that people are
trying to address across all these
various initiatives
great to be here thank you listen I mean
cities are places where humans live and
Thrive optimally it's been shown
throughout history you got population
growing all over the world but most
importantly it's about catalyzing
Prosperity I think you got to build new
cities so that more humans live more
prosperous lives and with technology in
the hardware space
um lagging in some ways the area that
people don't talk enough about is it's
acknowledging the governance space and
so instead of trying to change existing
systems create new ones and the delivery
mechanism to do so as a city so when you
see uh the existing systems you talked
about governance like what are the
governance mechanisms that uh when you
all say hey we got to create something
new like what are those governance
mechanisms that you want to recreate
sure when people think of government
it's a mixed basket of things but the
essence of governance comes down to
three things
good rules and the administration
thereof that everybody that's opted in
lives by the administration of justice
in a manner that's efficient and
effective and shared security so that
you don't have to worry about protecting
your physical Integrity or your
belongings more than your you know focus
on building value and wealth so those
are the three layers that are
essentially the provision of governance
within each of them I could go in great
detail but of the first one the most
important outcome of it is that you have
clearly defined and well protected
property rights which of course starts
with your body and as a derivative
they're off the goods and services that
you produce as a result and so the
things that are essentially needed to do
that start with a registry and then hop
into the other two layers that I
mentioned and so when you think about
starting over right or building from
scratch uh you all specifically at
prospera uh have gone to Honduras uh
you've gotten this zone for economic
development
in Roatan which is an island talk a
little bit about why Honduras why Roatan
and why pursue uh uh in some ways like
this jurisdictional uh uh Arbitrage of
some degree around this uh zone for
economic development sure well start
with the reasons why why I in particular
started why my group prospers in
Pursuits and and it's really about two
extremes of human condition on the one
extreme you have vast poverty around the
world you know you have likely billions
of people living substantially below
their potential and that's a tragedy for
a number of reasons and it's generally
more like a negative feeling you want to
try to fix something bad on the opposite
extreme of that there's tremendous
missed opportunity in the most
pioneering Advanced Minds everywhere in
the world where newer Technologies newer
services are not being created fast
enough or not being created at all and
that's also a tragedy and so Prosper
exists to alleviate the pain points that
results in those extreme conditions of
human existence okay
why Honduras and why rods on in
particular it's because after doing a
lot of research over about a decade it
was obvious that it was the best place
in the world to do what we're currently
doing how do you do the research like
when you go through the research process
are you like Googling are you like
visiting places like what does that
research look like it's both in my case
in particular I've been at this pretty
much since College in one form or
another but in 2014 started a venture
capital fund called New Way Capital that
started in partnership with Babson to
fund at the time called Enterprise
cities around the world and in
partnership with Babson we visited a
number of countries explored the
regulatory options that they had and it
was very experiential our partners on
the ground Shankar Singham in particular
you know he had already done a lot of
groundwork but research is not desktop
because a lot of what is being done is
about creating something new never been
done before so there isn't that back
then there wasn't the body of knowledge
so you could you know research that it
was about sitting with decision makers
explaining the vision understanding
their legal systems and procedures and
trying to gauge as best as possible
political capital and will as well as
the process that would need to be
followed and create opportunities for
them to validate that they were serious
and they can move the ball forward and
of all the countries in the world
Honduras actually did it in fact did it
twice when it came to performing its
Constitution to creating what is called
you know the special economic zones in
the region but zedes in particular that
go far deeper to enable reform than any
other special economic zone in the
region had up into the point on why does
Honduras want to create these special
economic zones like what's the value to
them 400s it's about foreign direct
investment job creation and about trying
something new it's a bit of a bit of an
experiment in how to solve the problems
that they've been plagued with and have
not been able to solve for decades and
looking at other places in the world
like Dubai and Hong Kong and Singapore
and saying well obviously a small piece
of land can generate unimaginable
prosperity for many many people what if
we try to adopt something like that
and when you see that playing out
um
what is the uh the way they measured is
it just pure like aggregate job creation
uh is it
um number of dollars invested like how
do they measure success in your opinion
the by far the most important kpi is
number of jobs that are paying you know
not only above minimum wage but you know
above average in the country which I
must say in Honduras unfortunately is
not a very high bar
um but it's about jobs primarily you
know the foreign direct investment
obviously is a catalyst for for jobs but
it's really more about jobs and as a
result the negotiation and the legal
system requires that 990 percent of
laborers are Hondurans of employees or
Hondurans of course you can have
Consultants you know if you're a
shareholder of a company you don't count
and that is provided you can find a
Honduran that's qualify for the
particular job that you're looking to
fill so it's really about jobs and so as
we watch this play out talk to me about
the process from uh hey we want to go
build these Enterprise cities to uh
Honduras has passed the special economic
zone legislation and now okay the the
foundation is laid we can go and
actually uh get executed what was that
process like sure it's worth is worth
mentioning
um mostly known these days for being CEO
of Prosper but I'm also a CEO of New Way
Capital which is a still a going concern
and so the process really starts with
new way capital and the way it looks
like as I mentioned earlier is you go
and in in an environment that as fast as
you can tell seems to be
Well Suited and has a population but
more importantly above everything else
there seems to be a political will to
drive substantial change and the the
desktop research version of it is you're
following either emerging leaders that
have not yet been elected or one way or
another taking power or that have taken
power and are saying quote unquote the
right things and it's it's you know hard
to differentiate from what they say to
what they do but at least if they're not
even saying the right things there's not
a good chance so back in 2014 2015 we we
prospected a number of jurisdictions
even including the US I was fortunate to
to be asked by Governor Doug Ducey from
Arizona to join a special committee that
he created as a co-chairman to explore
Prosperity zones in the state and we
went farther in one year than anybody
thought we would and I'm very bullish
about the possibility of when the time
is right pursuing it again in the U.S
basically in an abstract way it starts
with understanding whether or not
there's political capital and then
there's a back and forth of refining
what the leadership is actually looking
for and kind of customizing a bit what
we by now have developed as a standard
and then pushing the political slash
legislative process at some point there
is the enabling legislation rules and
regulations that go along with it and in
our case in Honduras in particular then
we go from there to creating the
intrazone statutes and Norms to then
literally groundbreaking and start
building which is where we are now for a
few years so the groundbreaking
component when most people think of
building they're like oh you're gonna
build a house like you have to build a
road just build uh uh sewage you have to
build a trash cleanup like there's a
city infrastructure uh I'm guessing that
gets built here like how do you go about
doing that yeah so indeed to build a
city you can say okay let's just go and
build City at the scale of City from day
one it's not generally the way you build
a business right generally you you build
a business by creating prototypes MVPs
and then scaling out from there in our
approach to new city building we're very
much follow following a startup approach
meaning obviously we have a master plan
in the beginning we have a vision of
where we think this is going to be
headed 10 20 30 years down the road but
unlike a typical Central State power
thinks you know China building what are
now ghost cities we're not deploying you
know overnight billions of dollars to
build roads and buildings that we then
hope get filled we do it in a very uh
scalable way so we have a master plan
and from there we say what would make
most sense as phase one of this master
plan and then who are the tenants and
let's go get them and then those tenants
and in most cases co-creators in our
world view then they helped set the tone
for what actually should happen next the
next and next so what you created as
your master plan initially you you know
in just a couple of years we're already
realizing it's it's very evolved but the
version we have now is much more real
because it's responding to actual market
demand as opposed to what we thought you
know four years ago would be the case
what's the first thing you had to build
once you get to Road 10 and you're like
okay cool this is going to be the site
what do you have to build well the very
first building we built we called the
beta building
and uh it was a building that was
purposely designed to be very flexible
it had both office and residential in it
and we were wondering are we going to be
pretty much initially more like a
tourist destination of hey here's the
place where a future city will come or
or we're going to have employees and
companies setting up and you know is it
going to be more tangible in that way
turns out that it was the latter we
never actually occupied the residential
uh spaces and we converted them we
bought the furniture but we never
actually laid the beds or anything like
that we instead set up work desks and
that building got quickly overrun with
market demand for workers that
um during covert were mostly remote
workers so we broke ground May 2020
right right in the smack middle of the
pandemic and so the first industry that
was very responsive was remote work
and then from there we built additional
modules and facility looking more
towards expanding office and then be
building the residential needs for the
workers that are coming to the island to
fill these high paying jobs yeah and why
would somebody want their workers to
work from Roatan is it a tax incentive
is it uh just the workers decided to go
there by themselves and their companies
don't even know where they are like like
what uh part of remote work made so
attractive so it's when people think
remote work you know it's more like
digital Nomads doing remote work that's
not the way it's actually working in its
Inception right now it's more the other
way around it's mostly U.S firms looking
for specialized labor and their
incentives is the ease of hiring and
working with them as well as the fact
that it's cheaper so for the Honduran
employee they're earning a lot more than
they would otherwise be earning but for
the company hiring them they're paying
them less than and they would pay say an
accountant or a lawyer in New York City
or Boston or you know or in Texas where
a lot of our customers are in so there's
a cost arbitration no doubts about it
but then there's the sense that you can
scale much more rapidly and with less
friction you know labor regulations are
you know it's it's an industry that most
people don't think of as an industry but
it is and it's highly regulated even in
the US Honduras uh it's highly regulated
too but within prospera we have a very
efficient way to provide labor Services
got it and so these are Honduran
citizens mostly that are actually living
and working in this environment the the
vast majority of the employees on the
ground are Hondurans that are either
from the island already or come from the
mainland to the island for these much
better job opportunities that we're able
to create how far is Roatan from
Honduras the physical distance between
the northern shore of Honduras and
rawatan is about 42 miles okay so so uh
decent enough where like this is a
decision a big decision somebody said oh
you're not going back and forth every
day it's a relocation decision yeah they
are daily fairies twice a day and then
their flights you know four or five
times a day but it's it's not a 20
minute drive to a different suburb this
is a you're relocating say from San
Francisco to New York or or you know
Houston it's a big decision got it and
uh when we think about row 10 as a uh an
island uh what has been the reception
they like this idea because there's
higher paying jobs they don't like the
decision because there's foreigners
coming there like what has been the
general uh it's been mixed
um and I think anything new is initially
faced with a bit of skepticism and
resistance and that's certainly been the
case uh with our vision but uh
historically given the political effort
that this took and the parties involved
in making it happen and the fact that in
in any democracy but certainly in in
this country whenever you have a change
of power you know whatever our
Administration did this just by default
bad right
um you know this was a major undertaken
by the prior Administration in power I
mean they had to reform the Constitution
twice so all the opposition parties you
know were throwing rock at it at some
point and now one of the opposition
parties is in power so it's been
inflated to some extent because of the
political aspect of it however what's
actually happening on the ground is that
we are building we're hiring we're
creating opportunities we're bringing
Technologies and industries that would
have never come to ruatan otherwise and
um
surely people are noticing and
many that were initially opposed to the
idea or what they thought this was about
are realizing that the reality of what
we're doing is actually not what they
thought and very much what they want for
the island so I would say that the the
opposition to the fluff or the of or the
erroneous idea of what we were about was
high and it's decreased even even even
the misconception it's decreased because
it's not a political year it's it's done
but the the understanding of what we're
actually doing is increasing and the
appreciation for it is increasing
exponentially so things have changed
quite a bit and and it's a very
welcoming environment for us but the one
thing about rawatan and one of the
reasons why we chose rawatan is because
aside from our project is generally a
very welcoming place for foreign
investment it's it's a it's a Caribbean
Island speaks mostly English former
British colony and they live primarily
off of Tourism and cruise ships for now
but flying tourists as well so it's a
very welcoming Island to foreigners
coming spending money investing hiring
it's it's not foreign if you will to
them it's just part of their culture
when you see
so much receptivity to the cruise ships
and and kind of that side of the tourism
uh is there a difference in the
receptivity like is it a different group
of people on the island who are
receptive to uh this idea of these
special economic zones or is it just
such a small island that there's only
really one group of people and and uh
there's one group of people and you know
what's interesting and there's a bit of
inside baseball but
in the beginning before cruise ships
started coming
there was massive opposition like you
have no idea the protests fires it was
massive oppositions and now if anybody
threatens the possibility of a cruise
ship docking because of whatever reason
Politics the opposition is against that
the the way in which the island has
embraced this thing which some groups
were adamantly against in the beginning
is amazing same thing with with uh
special regime that was created called
solitor it was a tremendous amount of
opposition in the beginning and now it's
one of the primary drivers of economic
activity on the island I think we're in
a similar trajectory you know as I said
anything new initially is faced with
persistence and but as you show that you
drive benefits then you're embraced and
on an island of this size which has less
than a hundred thousand people amongst
Three core Islands so it's a small
population now withstanding the fact
that the rawatan island itself is once
square mile larger than the island of
Hong Kong and we can draw some
comparisons later
so if you do things right you can
actually have a substantial impact in in
relative terms you know having we're
almost at a thousand jobs within the
jurisdiction that we're responsible for
so in less than a year and a half where
one percent of the population is
benefiting directly and when you look at
the immediately surrounding areas The
Village closest to us we have about 20
percent of that Village has a job
directly indirectly thanks to the
jurisdiction once you get to those
levels of positive impact before too
long it becomes anti-fragile
who's funding all this but like when you
think about uh uh the amount of capital
that ends up getting invested here like
where's that money coming from well I
mean our founder group started with
personal Capital the early stages of the
program
but it's very similar to a startup so
we've done seed rounds series a rounds
and now series B round
um and so it's a distributed network of
mostly High net worth individual
investors we do have a few institutional
investors
who are investing a la Venture Capital
they know or in the beginning now less
less and less but in the beginning they
know that the risks were frankly unknown
but assume high but that the benefit of
this succeeding financially and
otherwise was tremendous so it's you
know typical to uh to an early stage
startup and obviously critics will say
like oh so wealthy people are funding uh
the creation of new cities I hate that
that's bad
you know we can lay out all of their
arguments
um the other argument is like well you
need to be able to fund some you know
the money's got to come from somewhere
to be able to fund the creation of
something new how do you kind of think
through like uh the investor selection
right because I think that that's
probably a surface area where people
will naturally gravitate towards uh even
though you know I'm investing a lot of
companies
they do their own thing right and sure I
get reports and and that type of stuff
but but how do you think about investor
selection uh and then their
participation may be also in the
projects
so to the first point I mean generally
it's very wealthy people that make these
types of high-risk Investments is just
the way it is
um I think our investors have naturally
self-selected based on what we stand for
and what we're seeking to create you
know because the most important thing
about what we're doing in the early
stages was not how the city looks right
or any particular technology that was
being Advanced other than governance as
a technology so there's been
self-selection in that regard and and
and
the Common Thread revolves around two
Dimensions one a strong orientation
towards individual liberty and freedom
and property rights and everything that
comes with markets on the one hand and
on the other a strong alignment to the
sense that
you know the collective well-being of
basically humans generally is a good
thing to pursue right but you can't you
can't do it at the expense of the first
right in fact you only do it by
advancing the first but the sense that
not only can I get a huge return on my
investment but that this is the most
impactful most important thing that can
be done to actually Advance Humanity on
Earth maybe we'll make it into Mars at
some point but on Earth uh it is a
strong driver
now you know the nature of being an
early stage Venture means that the
number of investors because the amount
of capital is also small is small but as
we grow our model has a number of points
at which we essentially spin off uh
mostly the real estate development
companies land holding and what have you
into publicly traded and obviously with
crypto and tokenization we're very much
in line with that and so I'm not talking
about traditional IPO in an expensive
only when you're big enough sense
necessarily in fact uh our first real
estate development company St John's Bay
development company is already having
its Equity tokenized Equity you know the
tokens are listed in the securitized
platform under city as the token name
and the idea is that then it becomes
Ultra democratized anybody who wants to
own a small share or a big share
whatever they can afford of the
underlying most valuable asset that that
absorbs the value that's being created
can be part of it and you know the only
exclusionary criteria is that you have
to be so far you know going through a
kyc AML basically can't be in any of the
international Blacklist you know it's
treated as a U.S investment because the
the parent company is a U.S company has
to go through those levels of compliance
yeah
um do you worry about overlaying
complexity like obviously just building
the infrastructure is hard then there's
like the governance uh innovations that
uh you all are working on that's hard uh
then you have like geopolitics like that
that's uh complex to some degree and
then you add in things like tokenization
or Capital markets or whatever like
there's multiple layers of difficulty
here how do you think like do you deal
with all of it at once do you
sequentially say hey let's deal with the
first risk first like how you kind of
evaluate the risks and then approach
them
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep good sleep is a game changer and
the eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine I sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new each sleep pod 3 you can sleep
as cold as 55 degrees Fahrenheit or as
hot as 110 degrees Fahrenheit that's the
secret of thermoregulation better sleep
better energy get yourself and eat sleep
you can go to eatsleep.com pump today to
go ahead and get 150 off your order
eightsleep.com pump not only do I sleep
on it every night it literally changed
my life and I begged the founders to let
me invest in the company eightsleep.com
go get yourself an eight sleep pod and
get a better night of sleep
I think it's probably similar to how
Elon Musk probably thinks about Tesla or
SpaceX I'm not sure uh you know when he
was designing the Tesla cars
he was probably not just trying to
optimize for just the
electric motor you know
sometimes when you're trying to do
something that's transformative and
substantially better
it's not that you're stuck with it's
that it makes sense to innovate in all
the critical Dimensions that need
Innovations because the end product is
not a little bit better it's it's a
transformed product it's a zero to one
to some extent it's not the same thing
better it's a different version of a
product that delivers
a hell of a lot better service or
solution so
I don't think about it in that way I I
am cautious about undertaking complexity
and innovations that are not necessary
but we don't shy away from doing parts
that are critical to the vision just
because they haven't been done before or
because it could be on The Cutting Edge
of some technology you know you know
we're reserved but but
it's very risky to not take some risks
where it's important to take them
um
now the complexity under the hood is one
thing
the complexity in the user experience is
a whole nother thing and definitely the
user experience has to be and we work
hard at it being very simple and
straightforward you know just like when
you drive a Tesla you're driving a car
what the hell do you know what's under
the hood right it has a you know a round
steering wheel a gas pedal you know it
could have been redesigned but the
interface has to feel very similar when
you think of doing this as a company you
could have done it as a company you
could have done it as a non-profit or
you could have gone and basically been a
consultant working with a government and
said hey you all have to do this why is
that company the best vehicle it's it's
very important although it's a company
that's structured in a very unique way
but what's very important is a profit
motive okay our observation as to one of
the fundamental issues in how governance
is traditionally delivered as a service
is that the institution that delivers it
does not have a profit motive that
creates all sorts of of problems in our
model
you know process express it up as a
socio-economic development company in
all sorts and it's designed so that the
way in which it generates revenue and
profit is derived from generalized
prosperity in the jurisdiction that it's
managing in essence okay so the profit
motive is key one and two it's a capital
intensive undertaking and so if you want
it as we did to be able to raise capital
it has to be a company people have to
own a stake and the profits that will
eventually be generated need to be able
to result in a return on investment and
so that's how you raise Capital but what
about on the other side like why is a
for-profit company the best way to
actually uh govern right to build the
infrastructure and do all that well so
maybe I don't want to get into into too
much minutia although I'm happy to go
there you keep asking me however many
details as you want the way this
actually works is that the host country
in this case Honduras and others that
we're speaking with form of a form of
public-private partnership with our it's
called promote an organizer company okay
so between the two there is a special
jurisdiction that is formed in essence
that jurisdiction is a public entity in
in Honduras is a special economic zone
okay and it's created legally as a
political subdivision of the sovereign
state of Honduras so it's a governmental
entity through and through
what's unique about it however compared
to say other special economic zones is
the the depth of responsibilities and
authorities that it as a political
subdivision of the government of
Honduras has and that's important
because if you want to really deal with
the issues at the root and then
profoundly create better conditions you
can't just deal with surface stuff so
the jurisdiction has to be empowered to
deal with problems at its roots
and the other thing that's unique about
it it's the governance structure that
oversees and runs it if you will on a
day-to-day basis
that ladder component is formed at least
in the case of Prospero
um in in a in on a on a board it's
called the Council of the of the special
economics on the Prosper Council and
it's like a board of directors if you
will where the majority of those
directors eventually become selected by
the residents that have opted into the
special jurisdiction so it complies with
International Norms of democratic
government and representation but the
other part of the board is nominated and
appointed by the promoter and organizer
and so you have this interesting balance
between a for-profit interest that is
looking multiple decades into the future
and a resident class that you know is
essentially selecting people for their
most pressing needs immediately and so
we've created a structure we believe
that brings and combines the best of
what Both Worlds have to offer a very
Democratic way of electing
representatives and and having them
voice your thoughts and all the you know
and all the incentives and structures
that go along with that which is you got
to be popular to get elected and all
that combined with a different way of
looking at it which is a business
mindset long-term profit driven etc etc
so in this case
um it's the jurisdiction itself is
public but the way in which a lot of the
the decisions are made have have a
for-profit long-term mentality
associated with it and so that Council
how many people are on it there are nine
members of a council got it uh and it's
four or five come from the people versus
uh eventually five come from from the
residents there's a there's a
transitional period you know because in
the beginning there are no residents
right so you know landowners have some
seats in the beginning they promote an
organizer makes a nomination you know so
there's there's a mixture uh process and
the idea is that the residents will uh
be picking people who live there or
they'll be picking people who you know I
don't know could they pick uh
um Tim Cook you know from Apple could
pick somebody from the mainland of
Honduras to sit on it or does it have to
be somebody who lives there on National
Island that do not have to pick somebody
who physically lives there but in order
to be qualified to be selected by the
residents the person has to be at a
minimum an e-resident and obviously have
agreed to comply with the charter of the
zedia of prospera as well as the
Honduran Constitution got it what is the
e-resident a new Resident
basically is
a virtual form of residence it doesn't
give you physical access as a permanent
resident but it does for a select number
of days and it's the initial step of
opting into the jurisdiction virtually
okay okay uh you you've had to comply
you have to agree to comply with the
statutes and the and the charter you
agreed to resolve disputes through
either a selected arbitration Center on
a case-by-case or through the default
mechanisms of the jurisdiction and
ultimately you agree that anything you
do within the jurisdiction is running on
the on the common law code that was
created so there's a whole legal stack
that you opt in you you have a form of
identification as a member and and
you've agreed to abide by those rules
that doesn't mean everything in your
life but anything you do within the
jurisdiction when you identify yourself
as any Resident is running on the
Prosper legal stack got it uh is the
legal stack different than in Honduras
or America like in the sense of are
there rules that you all have that we
don't have or uh rules that we have that
you don't have
yes and no so it's important to
understand that the Zeta itself and the
Norms that it has adopted are considered
Honduran laws you know basically The
Zeta was created by the Honduran
Congress and the rules that it adopts
within the Honduran Constitution one but
once adopted
are literally under and lost now they
only apply within the jurisdiction and
or to those that opt into it but they
are Honduran laws okay
um now one of the unique elements of The
Zeta system in Honduras is that it
wisely observed that common law
Anglo-Saxon common law seems to be much
more effective at driving Prosperity
because it's more Dynamic more
responsive in a way it's decentralized
law versus centralized law in a in a
Napoleonic sense you know so it allows
the adoption of common law and so when
Prosper had to create the most base
layer of the tech stack for governance
we opted to do a restatement of
effectively American common law which is
itself an evolution of British and
international common law but it's it's
best this defined in the US through the
Ali American law Institute so it's it's
it's the it's the American common law
international common law system as base
it was stated to perfect it in our
opinion so as to be most protective of
private property and to
um and to be as Fair as possible within
our definition of what that means which
starts with individual responsibility
and freedom
and so it it's different than other
parts of Honduras and it's different
than in the US
but it's more similar to the US than it
is to Honduras outside of this area so
uh laws are great but they don't matter
if people can just go and do whatever
they want right like there's like a
decriminalization we see it with uh
marijuana in the United States right is
there's many places where marijuana is
technically illegal by the letter of the
law uh but the district attorneys have
said hey we're just not going to
prosecute these people anymore and so uh
kind of application versus letter of the
law can be very different another
example is uh they may say to the police
in the United States
um uh here in uh uh certain parts of
Florida uh the police are instructed not
to chase certain uh uh criminals based
on the crime that they committed so if
it's violent crime versus not violent
crime things like that and so it changes
the dynamic of whether people follow the
laws or don't I imagine in a place like
this where it is in its infancy and
being built out uh if somebody shows up
and starts committing crimes what
happens that person is there a police
force is there a court system that they
go through how does it work from an
application application standpoint not
just you know hey these are what the
laws are supposed to be followed yes I
would like to draw a distinction for the
way that I'm going to answer that
between let's say the the digital sphere
the virtual space and then the physical
space okay
um and and the digital transcends into
the physical in many ways but
as to rules and laws and words on paper
indeed they don't matter unless people
unless they can be enforced so let me
talk about enforcement you know in one
domain versus another
perhaps the most important domain
although it doesn't seem that way in the
short term is the fact that once you're
created as an e-resident on a platform
and you agree to abide by those rules if
there's a dispute or if you are a bad
actor you know your record gets affected
you know like basically if you're a
deadbeat if you if you've been invited
or asked to go to an arbitration you
just don't show up and that will show up
you know your e-residency will get
canceled
and or the fact that you have
outstanding bills and you know
will be known so there's a reputational
component that goes along with it and if
you're a bad actor you either never got
in or you get kicked out so so
definitely there's there's a cost and a
benefit to being part of the network
second thing is that we've created the
Prosper arbitration Center
to be compliant with and part of the New
York convention and that means that if
you and I have a dispute which by
default goes to the Prosper arbitration
Center we can contract out of it but if
we don't say otherwise that's where we
go
and I have been a bad actor and you get
an award against me from the pack the
cross arbitration center that is
enforceable in pretty much every country
around the world that is part of the New
York convention so I could be an
American you can be a German and that
award you can take it to the US and have
a local Court enforce it and they're
routinely enforced this is nothing new
it's just the way it works and it's much
more expedited so basically you get a
court order to enforce it and now then
you rely on say the local government to
seize property or chase a criminal using
their police force or whatever and then
that's when you cross into the physical
domain because ultimately a bad actor
that doesn't want to pay or doesn't want
to do what is right at some point that
coercion has to play a role right if you
want to take it all away and at that
point you need to you know involve the
authorities that control the the
Registries or the police so then let's
cross into the physical domain and you
can be in the US with an international
recognized arbitral award or you could
be with in prospera we're obviously the
prosparitration center award will be
recognized and so then what happens from
that point on if you have property
within the jurisdiction and that's in
the Registries the registrars are
mandated to react to those court orders
in essence likewise the police or the
security forces have to restrain you get
you out of the jurisdiction or bring you
physically to deal with the consequences
it's it's it's very similar with what
you would expect in a traditional sense
but the the difference in the Innovation
revolves around the incentive structure
just like driving a Tesla you know is
very similar it's a car we but the under
the hood makes all the difference in the
world
as to the question of are there is our
police is there like how do you deal
with that yes there is you know there's
ever law mandates in Honduras that the
zedi has its enforcement of of loss so
criminal law is that of Honduras and
applies through and through and then
civil law commercial matters are also
dealt with through arbitration and if
need be you know police can get can get
involved in our model we rely very
heavily and primarily on what under
common laws called self-help which is if
you can peacefully deal with the dispute
as long as you're not disturbing the
peace then do so and that includes you
know if you're a landlord and your ten
is not paying you can lock him out you
can turn off utilities you know it has
to be reasonable and all that and and
that's the fuzzy area of common law that
actually puts a lot more burden on the
individual because it says you got to be
reasonable and and who decides an
independent third party if it's it's not
prescriptive so all those mechanisms are
in full force within prospering under
address and it's part of the default
package if you will that when we set up
anywhere else is included
and when you think of the police like
that's probably one of the most
interesting things to me uh Prospero
doesn't have a military right doesn't
have a Navy uh that I know of uh doesn't
have an air force uh maybe you guys have
one secretly underground or something
um how do you think about like the
actual law enforcement both internal and
external uh so defense uh from a
military standpoint and then internal
policing
so National Defense
remains very much an exclusive purview
of the countries that we're working with
you know prospera is not a country
doesn't seek to be one doesn't have a
military and I don't think needs a
military in a traditional sense because
the military defense will be provided by
Honduras
yes and also because in a broader sense
a CEO of new way I can tell you that the
vision of Prosper has always been a
transnational network of interconnected
Prosper hubs that all of them have the
potential and eventually become
full-flawn cities and so in that in that
Vision the traditional Paradigm of a
standing National military doesn't fit
and it's also not as important or
necessary because you have other
mechanisms of ensuring that your
interests are protected you know at the
sort of macro level
uh so outside the city walls if you will
not figuratively not physically with
regards to internally yeah I mean
as I said the three layers of governance
security is is one of the most important
and ultimately it's about dealing with
Bad actors that are not gonna just do
what the law says to begin with OR the
contract or the arbitral award so you
got to be prepared
to use
Force defensively and defensively
includes the enforcement of agreements
you know because that's the guy or the
girl that's defrauding the third party
they're the ones that are committing
coercion to begin with
um so do you want me to go into like the
the specifics of how well we'll just set
up or so like another thing would be
let's say that somebody commits like uh
I I just jumped to the extreme right
like violent crime uh within the special
economics and like what happens to them
so if I go in and I'm a bad person and I
like beat up somebody in the special
economic zone right do I get arrested do
I get put in jail is the jail in uh the
special economic zone do I go to like
Honduran jail how does that work so
in the current form versus long-term
Vision the answer is different okay
today there are no physical gels in in
in prosperous jurisdiction in raw time
okay or the mainland for that matter
obviously they're jails in Honduras
everybody that is improsper is a citizen
of some country right whether it's
Honduras or some other country
few are Honduran Citizen and you commit
a violent crime
um
you not only can be prosecuted but the
city authorities are instructed to fully
cooperate and they will be all too eager
to make sure that you face Justice
and the country of Honduras as a claim
because you are a citizen of theirs
if you're a U.S citizen on the other
hand in the U.S
you know government has a claim okay so
the the preferred approach is ex you
know to send them to where they come
from with the evidence and the case and
said this person committed this crime
now you know take care of it take care
of it right
um so kicking them out in a way it's the
most tangible thing in the short term
having first reprehended apprehended the
person and then handing them to the
corresponding authorities over time is
inevitable and in fact you know as an
example of Honduras but I think it's
going to be the case in in other places
as well you know you don't want the zone
to then just export their Crim you know
whoever's committing crime outside you
know as of right now by law the
jurisdiction in Honduras they said it
has to pay the authorities to whom they
hand them so that they can be
incarcerated you know so the the
obligation of
of providing that service to society
falls in the jurisdiction nonetheless
the physical facilities might be outside
but the obligation is within the
jurisdiction so you pay for that service
over time I mean you would like to have
a world where nobody goes to jail and
that would wouldn't that be nice but you
know in reality you know I don't see
that being any different than at some
point the full Penitentiary system has
to be in place
again might look similar on the surface
but then when you think about the
incentive structure it's costly to run a
Penitentiary system it's bad business to
you know be oppressive with your with
your clients right so you might have
similar tools on the surface but the
driving force for how to implement them
is completely different and so they are
they're Prosperity enhancing incentives
as opposed to
um population control incentives or
whatever other incentives apply yeah uh
Balaji srinivasan recently wrote a book
uh the network State
um and uh I've talked with him at length
about it it sounds like you all are
implementing uh parts of that book right
uh although there may be some
differences how do you evaluate kind of
that thesis and like where do you see
overlap and commonality versus uh
differences
yeah I had I had the opportunity to read
an early version of it before it was
published because
um biology was kind enough to share it
there are some important similarities
and um and then there's some differences
I think
it's interesting because often very
smart people as biology is and and
others academics have a way to describe
things
that I either are already happening or
that others do without saying it in the
same way maybe that make more sense or
that have the right
Sizzle if you will yep when I first
heard of his concept and the way he was
putting it together my immediate
reaction is yeah of course I mean that's
kind of what we're working towards you
know this this International network of
interconnected City scale Prosper hubs
basically it's what he's describing
right I mean it's a network there's a
layer of governance they're real human
beings their physical locations you know
I would say that the the main difference
that I perceive so far
is that
in his model you can have a single
individual in a city effectively be a
node of this network State okay and in
my understanding of how to deliver the
services that Prosper seeks to deliver
you can't effectively do that at a too
small of a scale
you don't have the economies of scale on
the one hand nor do you have the
effectiveness to deliver the service
whether it is security or enforcement
when it's just one individual person in
Tokyo or wherever right or 10 you know
it might it might not make sense to do a
small neighborhood I know that 10 000
people and above definitely make sense
you know that's probably as low as I
would I would feel comfortable saying
you know you can do it as small as
sustainably for profit okay not as a
collective Community something you know
those they're different models that
maybe you can have a community of a
thousand and it's like a big HOA that's
not what I'm talking about I'm talking
about there's a service provider who's
in the business of creating the
conditions for people to have what they
need to be maximally uh prosperous and
that they seek to make a profit as a
result of it that's what I'm talking
about so there are many similarities I
would say that that's the main one that
we would only effectively call a Prosper
Hub a location that's both physically
big enough and has the vision to attract
at least 10 000 human beings living in a
community ideally however moving more
towards the 100 000 strong population
and as you see that play out like one of
the examples that he uses is like a
Google employee they have a badge they
go into a physical office but there's a
network of these offices uh you could go
from the San Francisco office and travel
to the New York office and uh you may
not have a dedicated desk but like
there's open desks and you can still go
get the snacks and uh you use that same
badge to get in like there's this
element of moving in between the
locations within the network is that the
general idea behind what uh you think
will happen with prosperity so what's
already happening with Prosper so that's
where the e-residency comes in okay
that's that's a global you know it's a
fact inside of a separate Tech stack
though it's related so that that
e-residency is Prosper virtual if you
will if you're part of that then you
have the base layer of access to
anywhere in the world this it's like a
wework if you will same thing you might
not have a dedicated space but you are
at least a club member
um within in Honduras alone there's
already five different
physical locations okay some bigger than
others some are as big as 400 Acres the
smallest one it's uh less than five
acres okay and it's just in a very
strategic location there's enough a
building that's being converted into
offices are going to be residences and a
few things so yes with your prospera
e-residences you enter in any one of
these five hubs uh as if you remember we
worked looking for office space
and
what are the risks with doing this like
when you all sit down obviously there's
the capital uh outlay that you have to
get through and you've got to be able to
build physical buildings but like what
are the risks that people may not
identify that you all have identified
that you're working to mitigate okay
guys you might think that okay X
sounds like a new genius football
formation it's actually not Charlie it's
your new favorite crypto trading app
you heard the man
[Applause]
you know there are definitely different
types of risks
um
Finance you know loss of financial
resources
is there
um
done right though that risk is very low
okay so the the only way in which you
actually lose all the financial
resources is because of you know a
natural disaster that just destroys the
only Hub you have up until that point
because if you've expanded then you got
diversification or you have you know a
expropriation by host government you
know something a bomb something like
that very very radical and therefore low
probability of happening
um
the risks that I think most people don't
even think about or appreciate is the
fact that you know there's a physical
Dimension to this you know the and when
you're seeking to
create something transformative and
something that
whether it's misunderstood or understood
from a very specific way quite literally
can be a threat to the most powerful
existing institutions in the world
yeah I mean they're you know people
they're you know people disappear when
they threaten uh powerful networks right
and and interest groups and and in parts
of the world where
where there's no rule of law right and
where
you sometimes people sometimes take
matters into their own hands you know
and you're poking at that bear to some
extent even those for good reason and
even though it actually lifts everybody
up including the interest groups that on
the surface fear threatened in the
beginning
you know there's risks that take you
know different actions you know I mean
governments are in the business of force
right but the cronies that leverage
governments to advance their interests
are also in the business of force often
through government and often not through
government have you guys faced that yes
what from who
you know not a liberty talk about it on
this open Channel but yeah uh suffice it
to say that uh the most valuable service
that we provide our members is security
but it it comes with a big cost and as
you think about that uh Honduras uh
Roatan
um somebody would argue Uh Uh there's
Big risks there there's uh uh violence
security all that type of stuff there's
other places in the world where it could
be much worse right and uh for example
if you had a location in Ukraine right
now during the middle of a geopolitical
conflict how do you think about
um uh having these areas where uh you
may have the service of National Defense
provided by the host country if you will
but you may not actually be in control
of it and there's all these like
external threats uh it's also the
sovereignty of nations of what you're
operating within like how do you think
of almost like the second and third
order or effect of security that you
might not have as much an impact on well
I think what I'm comfortable talking
about in this open channel is that as a
for-profit organization the best way to
deal with that is to have some degree of
diversification okay so if we have as
opposed to being in just one country or
one physical location you know if we're
successful within my lifetime we can
have say 100 of these spread out
throughout the globe yeah you got war in
Ukraine okay fine I mean you know one
answer could be well hopefully the
Ukrainian Army can do a good job right
the current answer is not well Prosper
has to have an army and go and send them
over there instead because of our
incentive structure is so different it's
like okay you're in you're in our
Ukrainian Hub come on over we're like we
got 10 others that will welcome you with
open arms because we want you to remain
a productive member of our platform why
because if you're productive you're
paying taxes you're buying real estate
you know it goes on and on and on so our
incentive is to then move expediously
and relocate the human beings and
minimize loss of life loss of property
but in a very business and sensible way
okay
so I mean that that would be you got to
grow in large enough to some extent to
be I would argue anti-fragile against
those risks because if you think about
it right now if you're in a country and
that's you know you're you're a citizen
of that one country and that country
goes to war and let's say it's Russia
then you can get drafted and you know
and where like where are you going to go
if you're part of this more networked
distributed
State you know and they have your back
and and and there is the right
incentives then okay that particular
geography or region of the world might
be going down in flames but then you get
distributed wherever your security can
be guaranteed yeah uh my mind jumps to
the physical security components of this
uh obviously one of the uh kind of maybe
uh less obvious but still risks is like
the regulatory risk
um I told someone I was going to talk
with you and they said uh oh ask about
uh the changeover in the government and
Honduras has led to uh different
perspectives on uh the special economic
zones and and frankly I Googled for
about two minutes and I got very
confused very quickly because there's
all kinds of stuff being written so so
I'm gonna talk to the source help me
understand uh what your analysis is of
uh the various administrations and like
how it seems like it could flip back and
forth in terms of the receptivity and
like what is the impact on the actual uh
business that you try to build given
that this could you know it's not a
unique thing to Honduras it'll probably
be something you're gonna have to deal
with in every single location you go
into sure I would like to
separate the zeded program
versus the instantiations of sadness and
also the actual said that's being
created of which Prosper was the first
um what is most susceptible to the
pendulum swinging is the program as a
whole
and in fact in Honduras this new
Administration was against their
understanding of it and it's important
to make that distinction as well the
understanding of what it is or was
versus the reality of it they were very
much against their understanding of what
it was and indeed they passed laws to
repeal the program
and so as of right now no news edits can
be created okay they killed the program
as a whole for the creation of new says
however
the prosperous Ave was already created
and it's like grandfather being
grandfathered in to some extent and not
just created but in on the face of the
law itself guaranteed by the Honduran
Constitution there is at least a 10-year
transitional period no matter what but
in the case of prospera through an
international treaty that applies to it
is actually 55-0 years of transitional
you know guaranteed stability of that
Arrangement so while you can and they
did get rid of the program to create new
zevis the existence of those that were
lawfully created and I can speak for
prosper is guaranteed for 50 years
of course there are people who would
like to not see that be the case you
know radical factions within the
government for ideological or other
reasons mostly based on his
understandings but even if they fully
understand it there are some people who
really don't like what we stand for and
what we're trying to do and I won't go
into their motivations
but by and large
the Honduran government the the people
we speak with they get the rule of law
to some extent really matters and they
can't just override acquired rights and
not just the government but also the
strongest economic groups of the country
realize that if they allow one major
investment such as prosperous in the
country
to just be overwritten in that regard
than they're next in line you know they
might think they have nothing to do with
Prosper but the legal foundations upon
which prosperous stands are the
strongest that any business in Honduras
has available to them and so those are
eroded away then nothing else matters
and they get that so I actually feel
very good that the the more sensible
Minds if you will in the country are
will prevail you know I could be proven
wrong but I the evidence I'm seeing so
far is very optimistic in that regard
now uh just to close this particular
topic about Honduras and I can tell you
more broadly in a global sense it's not
as if they're not
um
legitimate concerns
by groups about what Zetas Could Have
Become
right and perhaps some imperfections in
how the original legal structure was
created I'm not speaking about Prosper
specifically necessarily just the law of
the said they could have been used in
manners that would be very
counterproductive to say national
interests
but that does not mean that the way that
they were actually created materialize
those risks and in the case of prosper
in particular none of those risks ever
materialized and the extent to which
there is some potential opening for hey
you know it could be then that's where
people sitting down talking about it and
resolving the issue is very viable so
knowing what I know about what the
concerns are the realities of our
platform I have no concerns like
concerns for example like environmental
degradation violation of Human Rights uh
violation of national sovereignty uh
hosting of you know criminals all these
all these concerns
you you know it's easy for people to
concoct how what a limited understanding
of the of the jurisdiction is could
result in the maximization of those for
example if you understand the level of
legal autonomy that the jurisdiction has
you can say Well they're autonomous to
do all sorts of things therefore they
could do bad things right
but it's not true for each of one of
those things for example when it comes
to the environment in prospera not only
is it already Bound by International
treaties that protect you know all the
things that are now protected nationally
in Honduras but they're very strong
internal Norms about zero tolerance for
say hurting the coral reef which is the
most precious you know natural resource
in rawatan uh when it comes to say
criminality you know the the full
criminal code of Honduras applies inside
there is full extradition you know that
still applies so if you can't be a
criminal in Honduras and within prosper
and then not be exposed to International
extradition
um
you know so I can go on so those are the
main ones that people beside as a as a
fear but they're not based in facts got
it so it's basically if I look at what
is possible and go to the most extreme
uh potential negative things uh the
equivalent would be
um well if people can drive cars then
they may hit people like walking across
this uh across the crosswalk and
therefore no one should drive a car
because they may hit people and so uh
there's risk reward uh or trade-offs and
and all of these things uh and
rational people try to get the most net
positive uh while understanding the
risks and trying to mitigate risks along
the way for example that would be a
reasonable way to look at it yeah okay
um what's your pitch to people why
should they move there like is it like
hey literally come physically move here
is it become an EU resident like what is
the the thing that
um you want people to consider doing uh
and then maybe what is the difference
between like why should they become an
e-resident versus like go physically
move there
well there are many reasons but of
course you can start with an e-residency
but the most impactful part of it is the
people that are already moving to do
very cool and interesting things so uh
rawatan as a whole it's a beautiful
destination you know blue transparent
Waters white sand
um it's a great place to grow a young
family you know we've we've now have uh
an internationally best standard School
within the jurisdiction
But ultimately it's about the process of
co-creating I would say you know it I
think that the pitch is if you want to
be part of
building the future that we want to see
right and dealing with the most
important layer of what it means to be a
civilized society and how you get that
if you want to be part of that then
we're at the very tip of the spear for
that you know the frontier to some
extent
and the cool thing is that you don't
have to become an expert in governance
per se because our service to the most
pioneering co-creators in the world is
to create the environment for them to do
what they are either already in pursuit
of or would like to be in pursuit of for
instance if you want to be in the most
advanced digital manufacturing
technology using robotics with locally
sourced natural materials to build
beautiful but aesthetically beautiful
functionally Advanced and amazing
buildings then you're improsper as is
the case right now you know our
pioneering development called bayavo has
a company started called circle of
factory that is doing exactly that in
fact there's three robots in the whole
Latin America including Mexico doing
robotics manufacturing or building
components three in the whole Latin
America including Mexico two of them are
in real time with improsper okay if you
are at The Cutting Edge of financial
Innovation and you want to you know
build a bank from scratch digital or
just run on on bitcoin for everything
then you're in prospera you know
Prospero right now has the only ATM
Bitcoin ATM of the bay Islands it's the
only part of Honduras that has lawfully
acknowledged the Bitcoin basically is is
currency and should not be taxed as a
commodity and what have you and you can
pay your taxes using Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies so if you are The
Cutting Edge of finance and you want to
leverage everything that crypto has to
offer in a lawful way et cetera then you
come to prosper if you're at The Cutting
Edge of healthcare and you want to deal
with anti-aging gene therapy really
pushing the boundaries of what the body
can do
safely but you know not not stuck with
paperwork for 20 years just doing it
right then you're improsper you know the
most advanced gene therapy company that
I know of in the world is operating in
Prosper doing clinical trials and soon
next year opening up to the broader
market and they're falling super high
standards of both ethical and safe
parameters but they're improsper because
that's the environment that caters to
them so if if you're in the cutting oh
and and I mentioned the school earlier
that's guidepost Montessori with Ray
gern you know if if you if you believe
that education makes the biggest
difference for your kids and you don't
want to be restrained either by stupid
curriculums that indoctrinates them in
things that add no value and in fact
destroy value and you want them to have
a great experience not software that
then you're improsper and you're
building you know the most Innovative
most beautiful school that there is in
the region
um so those are all reasons to be there
then that's the sort of innovation
Cutting Edge part of it but also if you
want to have a low-cost way to operate
because taxes are very low because labor
is is very productive compared to its
cost then you're setting up you know
perhaps in the industrial park and you
know we have people looking at car
assemblies you know bulletproof car
assemblies you know you're looking at uh
Pharmaceuticals you're looking at bpos
and your Competitive Edge there is
actually a cost Advantage it's not that
it's the most innovative business model
but you can execute your business model
with the lowest amount of cost on the
edge that really make a difference
Pennies on the dollar
when you see this um and these companies
come what's the biggest surprise that
they have is it the cost of Labor is it
the ease of operating within the special
economic zone like what what are they
surprised by
that we're real and it's actually
happening I mean honestly that's the
biggest thing that people tell me you
know yeah I read about this I've heard
about the idea of broadly a bunch of
groups are talking about it but like
it's I see the buildings coming up and
my goodness you know like they're like
within the week I was here another floor
went up yeah the biggest surprise is
that it's actually physical it's
happening it's beautiful but it's real
yeah and then within the realness of
course it's like oh got it so I I get
the decentralized regulatory model you
have it's easy to comply with fairly low
cost in terms of taxes and everything so
but but that is
it's hard to explain it that that
doesn't matter as much compared to the
fact that it's real from a surprising
perspective so there's a lot of people
who are going to listen and watch this
and they're going to be like this is
[ __ ] right like like the whole like
is it real is it not real whatever
um what are like one or two either
anecdotes or data points that you can
point to that uh show progress has been
made so far right is it number of
buildings people who have moved there
like how do you think about uh this is a
data point that is showing we're headed
in the right direction
for me the most important metrics is the
number of co-creators
engaged in in building our vision okay
and uh we're about to hit 15. and it
seems like a small number like 15 not
even 100 right I mean and I would say 10
really are the ones that are really
pushing shoulder to shoulder with us
um but for each one of these co-creators
what is happening is that they are
pushing on the edge of something that is
Meaningful makes a difference could not
have otherwise happened in that way was
it not because of prosper and them
succeeding is something important being
solved like I mentioned the circular
Factory for example I mean and this
involves uh The Architects from London
they've been at the vision that they're
now being able to realize and prosper
for 20 years before we started talking
20 years one of the leading
architectural firms in the world with
with technology we resources basically
could do anything anywhere in the world
in common in terms of projects and it
took Prosper for them to start to
actually realize in physical reality the
project that is available when you see
it on our website and and and when you
see it say why I mean it seems like it's
okay it's a nice good looking building
but when you scratch under the surface
and again it's about what's under the
hood and you realize that there is a a
full technology stack that go rules from
democratized social sales so as to
create communities from online to on
land
and that the facilities that are created
in a virtual environment can be clicked
and then built through robotic
technology that that is sustainable and
circular and you say okay you know what
that's pretty damn cool
so what I would say to people that that
that just come and visit you know check
it out I mean the website is is a
website common you know rawatan is an
amazing place you can get to there
directly from Miami every day they're
direct daily flights Miami raw down and
back also from Houston and then there
are other cities during the high season
but come stay we have a hotel a
beautiful Resort we you got a golf
course you got a beach club
um you know their Villas and come stay
visit and then you know you make up your
own mind yeah it um it's a it's a pretty
good strong pitch where can we send
people to find more about Prosper if
they say hey this sounds interesting uh
I just want to learn about this what's
the website sure well I mean prospera.hn
is the the public website you can hit me
up on Twitter under Eric Bremen as well
as I still have I have a low enough
volume of direct messages that I do read
them
um and so you can hit me up there and um
yeah those are those will be the two
best places awesome I I really
appreciate this this is uh it's
fascinating to kind of think through and
and I think as uh more and more people
within the United States and
internationally think about where they
live uh the pros the cons the political
climate the governance uh security many
of those different factors uh uh it
feels like uh you all are on the tip of
the Spear of this idea of like well what
if we just build from scratch somewhere
new
um and uh I think it would be
fascinating to kind of watch this play
out over uh over the coming years so I'm
excited for you guys and I appreciate
your time today to uh to help explain it
thank you and if you don't mind let me
just say something that that I hopefully
helps position this part of the world in
raw time in particular in people's minds
uh you know the GNC in the Mediterranean
used to be a place where where you know
the the most advanced of human
Innovation you know in governance
technology was taking place and
obviously you have the Roman Empire and
you know things were happening there
the way I see the world so things have
shifted ever more towards the West right
part of western culture and all that
and I don't know maybe maybe the Roman
Empire is not where it used to be maybe
it's more like where we're sitting right
now
and instead of the GNC maybe it's about
the Caribbean Sea because if you look at
both the geopolitical realities around
that part of the world as well as the
geographical realities around that area
of the world where you can if you were
to imagine a perfect place that is close
to the major hubs of economic activity
talent and capital yet is very
distributed lots of relatively you know
small places where you can make a big
difference I would say that place in the
world today is in the Caribbean Sea and
then beyond that I would say further
that rawatan is a very very unique very
very special place in the world and
through a series of historical accidents
perhaps and very unique people that have
become involved is extremely well
positioned to be no less than the Hong
Kong of the Americas I mean it even has
a similar size the Topography is similar
the the the climate is similar but the
the physical location obviously the
legal realities the history it's the
former British colony it's near a
Mainland that is in desperate need of
catalyzing a huge economy because it has
a capacity and the geopolitics today of
near Shoring and bringing all that which
you know has been on the mainland of
China to the Western Hemisphere where
Roatan is quite literally across no more
than 40 miles of distance where you can
take a 15 to 20 minute passenger drone
flight back and forth centering yourself
in the Emerging Center for crypto
Finance in the world
with a Mainland population and
geographical location that gives it a
great Advantage for near Shoring I mean
it's like we're replicating Hong Kong to
Shenzhen in our times with the most
modern Technologies available made
possible thanks to the Prosper
Regulatory and legal environment uh
really exciting times I hope thank you
very much for having me you obviously
have a great following and people that I
think uh by and large see the world in a
similar way sort of unrestrained by the
by the paradigms that exist and that
want to do things new not just because
they're different than new but because
we know deep down inside then it can be
a hell of a lot better right we know
that even in our case when we live in
this and we're Miami what an amazing
place to live in but we know that
there's a bunch of artificial
limitations here that keep us and a
group of us from getting to where we
want to get and you know prosper in raw
down is a place where you go to be
Unshackled from all that and in the
process help create something truly
transformative that will shape our world
yeah pretty cool I appreciate the time
today thank you